1000 personen treffen die wirklich
großen entscheidungen in diesem land
gerne das sagt der soziologe michael
hartmann
er forscht zum thema eliten und das ist
sein forschungsgegenstand die deutsche
wirtschafts elite die chefs der dax
konzerne keine frau dabei die meisten
aus großbürgerlichen verhältnissen
über ein halbes jahrhundert fast kommen
vier von fünf vorstandsvorsitzenden
aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden aus den oberen
vier prozent der bevölkerung da hat sich
überhaupt nichts geld hat das waren 1 2
prozent von jahrzehnt erzählt warum
spielt herkunft in deutschland immer
noch so eine große rolle
er hat eine ahnung davon service.de mir
kam erst mit acht jahren aus der türkei
nach deutschland
er machte abitur als jahrgangsbester und
konnte dank stipendien studieren als
erster aus seiner familie an der uni
trifft hauptsächlich auf söhne und
töchter aus deutschen akademiker
haushalten und die haben viele vorteile
sie sind finanziell meist besser
abgesichert karrierefördernd ist häufig
auch das beziehungsnetzwerk der familie
und sie wachsen selbstverständlich mit
den hobbys und interessen der oberen
schichten auf und wenn man anders
aufgewachsen ist
man muss das nicht als schwäche denn ich
glaube da ist so eine große gefahr für
viele dass die sich dann nicht für gut
genug halten oder nicht mithalten können
obwohl es ich versuche zu betonen nicht
besser oder schlechter ist sondern
einfach mal anders ich glaube die kunst
ist es
sich selbst treu zu bleiben und trotzdem
seinen weg zu gehen und wir sind systeme
im voranzukommen
genau das vorankommen aber ist für
migranten und arbeiterkinder schwer denn
die top-position sagt der elite forscher
werden nicht nur nach leistung besetzt
es gilt das sogenannte
ähnlichkeitsprinzip ähnlichkeit heister
sitzen seit jahrzehnten große männer aus
den oberen vier prozent der bevölkerung
bürgerlich großbürgerlich die erkennen
sich an der sprache also dass sie den
genitiv ordentlich verwenden statt die
die erkennen sich an der
selbstverständlichkeit mit der sie
auftreten an der gestik und sie suchen
im grunde jemanden der so ist wie sie
selbst nur eben 20 jahre jünger ist er
der elite ähnlich genug letzten 20
jahren auf einen so ich weiß dass du mir
ganz elegant besten leistungen und ron
artest aber manchmal wenn man das nicht
kennen würde wird man auch auf ersten
blick so aus einer einwanderer familie
in der das geld sehr knapp war und die
abschluss und promotion in seinem umfeld
ungewöhnlich doch er will karriere
machen was fair sein sollte es eben die
die mobilität um von unten nach oben
aufsteigen zu können dass man wenn man
möchte dass man wenn man den griff hat
auch den ganzen sachen in einer
lebenszeit sich zu eigen machen kann
die chancen für den beruflichen aufstieg
aber sind immer noch ungleich verteilt
in ganz europa und die eliten oft weit
weg von den alltagssorgen und alle
anderen das problem der mietwohnung zu
finden haben viele von ihnen neben leben
gehabt schon ihre eltern nicht
sie haben eine andere einen anderen
bezug zur normale lebensqualität was für
sie selbstverständlich ist ist für
andere luxus wir haben nur studie
gemacht vor ein paar jahren und das
ergebnis bei reicher und wohlhabende
elite angehörige aufgewachsen sind um so
gerechter finden sie die unterschiede in
der gesellschaft
also wer alles hat findet es meist gut
dass nicht alle das gleiche haben
der blick auf die gesellschaft abgehoben